early in june we find out that there
will no longer be agents that we
traditionally go through so we usually
have kind of middle agents to offer hajj
packages now we were told that this
would be centralized by our online
system that you would have to register
and then there would be a lottery to
draw and then if you were selected then
you go forward to pay there are loads of
problems one is that when you're filling
out the form for example they want you
to
send in your certificates and your
passport pictures and your pictures and
they can't be over a certain size for a
lot of people a lot of muslims in the
west that this is a once in a lifetime
thing it's a religious duty it's a very
spiritual experience and people expect
to face challenges but i think that it
feels like this has happened in a
haphazard way with just weeks to go for
people to leave
people still uncertain what the process
would be and how it would work and keep
in mind there's been culved for two
years and many people haven't been able
to go and even this year the numbers are
reduced to a million i think 850 000
outside the kingdom and this lottery
system hasn't really worked in terms of
payments in terms of the visas in terms
of lots of things many people have been
kind of ruled out like not everyone is
tech savvy and can resize images and do
things like that but also what happened
was that when the draw had taken place
we found out very late that we had been
selected and then the packages that we
had seen for example we were offered uh
seven and a half thousand pounds per
person which is still a lot of money
when we initially went on once we've
been selected that same package is now
ten and a half thousand pounds that's a
lot of money
to pay for something that's supposed to
be a religious duty it feels like there
are people here that are making money
out of this it's like kind of religious
tourism some people for example weren't
able to go because they just didn't have
the extra cash so there was a difference
in price selection but also
it took me around 26 attempts to pay the
system kept rejecting my payments even
though they're paid
some people have said that the
application is still pending other
people have paid and they've said it's
been rejected or there's been a refund
other people haven't got their visas or
like me you've paid you've got your visa
there's still no ticket information and
i leave in a few days and we're still
waiting for that ticket information
and what we're being told is don't go to
the airport until you've got that ticket
information
but the hajj is very close so people are
getting very very anxious
[Music]
you